[Music]
all right hello and um welcome back
everybody actually welcome to me I guess
it's been a couple of months since I've
been on planet's YouTube channel I have
many around but not on YouTube because
um the the classes that I teach when I'm
in town are not youtubeable I guess
they're kids classes yeah
yeah so
um the big thing that I want to talk
about is thank you Caleb for allowing me
to do the GM choice because this is my
spring break week and I'm in town for
the most of it
um but uh I really wanted to just kind
of circle back to some of the classic
ideas and how you can try to implement
them in your games so I'm gonna use one
of the games that I played recently as
an example and that's going to be a
nimson Indian game so uh chess bunzo
will know it because I already showed
that game to him but uh and he actually
played a couple nice games like that too
so if you watch his streams you may see
some of those
sorry I'm putting you on spots
um but the first the first
YouTube a video that I did for the club
was also a very nice Nimble as black
that I played so I thought this would be
a nice way to also use that as an
example so you can definitely find
that's linked somewhere down below
in the description thank you Ben Simon
so
um without further Ado I'm gonna jump in
I'm still gonna talk a while during it
so don't worry about that but uh the big
thing that we want to do is show
classical and where I potentially messed
up a little and where I did great or
where I could have done better so those
are the big things that we want to try
to keep in mind now
um let's see the game so this was a game
that I played in pan AMS well actually
long story short I used to be at SLU but
then I got into Medical School moved to
Mizzou missiles like an hour and a half
okay actually hour 45 away learn how to
drive because I got into music that was
weird
and so I don't leave this thing to lose
anymore but I'm in town every like two
to three weeks just for a weekend but
so I played for Mizzou team now wait
actually I should be showing off the
jacket I guess
there we go
hopefully this will make my new coach
very happy
uh but yeah so this was the first panel
that I played for them and it was pretty
fun it was in Seattle it was very rainy
but it was a really cool game I really
enjoyed this specific game because it
kind of
um it kind of gave me that nice idea
that's just because I wasn't
100 up to date on my openings it didn't
mean that I can't play decent chess so
I'm talking about that because I don't
practice openings as much as I used to
when I was playing Super professionally
and I was playing like you know 400
games a year
so I don't do those anymore but I still
try to keep up to date with opening
Trends and like tricky stuff but
I would prefer to play something less
theoretic based and more ideas and more
like comfort and like more like I love
to grab a nice Center I want to be able
to keep my king safe I want to have like
tensioner Center I want to develop my
pieces places that I know they belong so
I try to keep more my like opening
principles rather than some crazy cool
move that I don't understand and it
needs to be like engine based this by no
means this doesn't mean that you can't
do that you definitely can as long as
you know exactly what you're doing
engine based that is totally fine just
just make sure that you spend enough
time to learn the engine moves the
master games those
okay I have a question about what would
I do against Queen C2
um I've actually experienced a lot with
it I go back and forth A lot of times if
I if my opponent doesn't necessarily
know what I will be playing I play
Knight C6 in Queen C2 because
um I've just had a good experience with
this line especially in like a little
bit lower levels because I can try to
easily get a nice Center like this open
up my bishop and
um in my experience they tend to also
try to close up the center which is
great that's exactly what I want which
means I can try to do a king side attack
so
uh again Queen C2 and ic6 is not one of
the top engine recommended moves it's a
playable move and it's like a thousand
Master games but Castle is the main line
D5 is pretty cool C5 is pretty cool
um I chose Knight C6 I still go back and
forth between the lines but Knight C6 if
if somebody played against me right now
I would probably go for Knight C6 oh my
God they're gonna use this against me
um
yeah like F3 is another cool one F3
requires more Theory based and Caleb
keeps or at least kept playing this when
I played a couple games with him and it
was not fun
um I've experienced a lot with F32 but I
wanna today I want to focus more on this
specific Pawn structure
um I have a pretty cool book
recommendation
um it's by Ivan sokolov I think it's
called winner winning middle game ideas
I think
um and it's it does cover this specific
Pawn structure and the trap and then
this specific like ideas
pretty nicely
um I did in school into all of the book
because some of it the chapters just
were not the I would never play them but
this I remember this chapter wasn't
there and I liked that
so I like to play this early C5 now my
whole strategy is based on these two
pawns so what I intend to do is long
term I am never ever probably going to
take this unless it's a guarantee for me
to eat C4 so
um my big plan is to try to develop like
this
try to potentially join a rook C8 I know
there's a lot of arrows and potentially
make this Rook attack on C4 so that
would be the only time I would take on
D4 to attack on C4 but that's kind of
the general idea now I may or may not
play D6 because sometimes this D6 Square
will be useful for other pieces right on
the pond
um so keeping that in mind this is a
very clear weakness for my opponents but
this by no means is like a guaranteed
one for me I mean white is still
surviving playing there's nothing wrong
with light there they do have to be very
more aggressive with their Pawn attacks
so they gotta start pushing this eef and
they if they can start F5 E5 if they
start attacking on King slide and busted
um so like you need to like is black
need to be very careful about the move
order that I'm presenting so
um yeah so those are the general ideas
to keep in mind my opponent played Pawn
E3
um and if I'm not mistaken um he was
like 18 1900 USCF so he was he had a
very respectable writing there was
nothing wrong like I mean I mean he's
also a college you know student and I
think he was Stanford A or B and like
if I if my online checkup pans out
correctly I think he was excluding some
PhD in Biochemistry or anyways so again
he was also not a very professional
chess player so I didn't expect him to
know everything there is to know about
this position but
um he did know enough so I say that
because he is correctly developing he is
trying to set up for E4 and he's not
necessarily rushing into Knight f3s
Knight F3 is totally fine too
so he won 92 which again makes total
sense he's trying to push the F and E
Pawn now the one thing that I do want to
emphasize is if my opponent had played
E4 I would need to be more careful
because this is about to come up so
question for chat and audience what do
you think we should do here as black
sorry
uh possible but I wouldn't play it
because I think H6 gives more weakness I
my opponents will definitely want to
start pushing stuff on kingside so I
would rather not touch these pawns
unless I know for sure
oh I remember Patrick from
way before in the chat
again possible but it doesn't stop
Bishop G5 we want to make sure that
we're not dealing with Bishop G we are
like dealing with Bishop G5 we're not
allowing it too easily
too many people in the chat are saying
D6 now
Patrick yes the classical idea is to do
these but I don't think that this is
like that's the idea but it doesn't mean
you have to do it right away it is a
little slow I agree
so try to keep your focus on Bishop G5
how can we try to deal with it
I like that yes Knight E8 Chad is also
catching up I see just Boone's also
making a smile like I know this
yeah Knight E8 another problem another
problem at 98 stops is this because if
you put a four I will play F5
um and I remember I saw this a bunch of
classical games
I want to say like 10 years maybe 12
years ago from a coach that I had back
in Iran that he showed me like how this
Pawn got pushed and like even black when
black played F6 it was still extremely
uncomfortable
so it's really important to try and
avoid these now
my opponent didn't play E4 immediately
he castled and I was like you know what
I don't want to deal with this I'm going
to play 98 there is nothing specifically
wrong with 98 but Bishop A6 is a little
bit more convenient because I'm gonna
wait for E4 then I would play 98. this
is pretty much what happened in the game
anyways
um but the move order I think it matters
so if you will play this in your own
game maybe servers Bishop A6 1098
um and just to kind of go a little bit
deeper and give you some examples of
some cool games
um some of the games that I found is
like Carlson played Naka in 2020 and he
lost so Naka won this as black they get
the way that that game was played I
believe was take take
and I believe here G6 was played
and Naka just kind of these two pawns
are super weak so he just kind of
reorganized his power and I mean the
game went on longer but I just kept the
came as this much in the chat in my
notation so feel free to look that game
up yourself so again this was a game
that Carlson Naka played in 2020
actually this was a Carlson tour final
cool
um another game if you want to try to
think a little bit I guess more recent
slash younger generation is
um pragnananda versus Essie Pinko and
they played Knight E7 here I would
prefer G6 just because I have more
experience with that G6 line and I
really want to try to get that Knight
out there but this was also a very
interesting game it kind of turned out
to be a bust for a supreme court though
this was 2020 Tata steel so I
again I don't think Knight E7 was the
reason that scpenko got a little um
whoopsy-doopsy in this game but G6 makes
complete sense to me because every time
that they're attacking this G6 because
you may try to go Knight G7 at those at
some point in some protect it that way
and we will look at my game too so we
can compare but I'm kind of trying to
give you other points of comparison as
well
so there is this um
yeah so let's see there was another line
I also wanted to talk about
yeah if not G3 early uh this was another
game that was a little bit older and it
was also a rapid game so again it
doesn't question the accuracy but just
kind of to give you all the information
you can see how close
um they all look like the pawn
structures the attacks on C4 C3 and so
this was a game between Ivan sokolov
um the guy who I mentioned wrote The
cookbook and Alexander restaurant and
this was a rapid game that was played in
20 oh sorry 2007. so keep that in mind
as well in case you want to have a more
comprehensive database anyways back to
the game our 98 2. E4 I think I should
have played Bishop E6 first I think that
would have been more comfortable I
played F5 but let me just give you more
information about Bishop A6 next move I
played Bishop Basics so again I
transposed into this position I was
transposed into this exact position
but just to kind of give you idea so
this would have been very similar to my
game and uh actually pretty much exact
and this was a game that was played uh
two different times by useful and
carpoof
so useful white carp of black and both
times carp of one uh one of them was in
1993 one of them was in 1989 so a little
bit more classic and those two games are
the key games that I remember when I
whenever I played a specific line
because
um I those were the first kind of games
that I saw that had this specific Pawn
structure in it so I really like that
but like Bishop e3s I I kind of know
that since carbon flight G6 it's okay
since karpov delayed has D6 it's okay
um so for example in one of the games
karpuff took and then just got D5
and kind of got these trades going on
and went to this end game
um I wouldn't do it just because I don't
trust my own end game skills doesn't
mean anything about the game I would
rather keep the Queens on and focus on
those two
um so I play better when I have more
material so I wouldn't do that but
Carlos did so if you want you can
another game that carpool played uh
actually a couple of years before that
was Knight D6 totally fine and use the
book took he took took took two two two
two oh well it takes and he got a lot of
attacks going on but it didn't really
pan out and this ended up in waiting for
carpoof and this was a very important
tournament it was a candidates in 1989
so
I think probably carp have played this
in like 1980 in 1989 and he was like you
know what let me switch it up for the
next game so
I don't know the exact details of that
anyways I said that so I can show you
what happened in the game so
um my 1.9 G3 I played G6 you see it kind
of turned out the exact same although he
could have considered taking and that
was another game that that was actually
a game that Carlson Naka played right
that's um 2020 Carlson tour final
so
um he played not G3 I played G6 he
played Bishop E3 and here I was like
look I really really don't feel like
taking over here I definitely could have
and that was another game that was
actually that was two games that was
played
um with yusu puff as white so these are
again all 1990 something games so
um yusufu played this this was a game
that uh yusufu had with karpov right and
there was another game that you suppose
didn't have with carp of surprise and he
his opponent played Knight A5 I can only
assume that it's playing on C4 which is
totally fine
and but usually went on to win this
again personal preference I would rather
avoid the end game Shenanigans as long
as possible so I just didn't get into it
um Knight A5 would have also been
interesting and if take take take take
for gift two I think this was also a
nice choice and I could have considered
like p5s maybe and then this would be
like a relatively weak Pawn maybe long
term I could try to attack that pawn
um but for me I was like I don't really
want to put myself in a dangerous
situation so I played Queen E7 I was
still holding up hope to play Knight E
Knight D6
so I got that going and with 96 that
would bring an extra attacker right
so I think that's why my opponent played
E5 to be honest I don't think E5 was the
best move so I'm gonna go ahead and ask
what do you guys think white should have
done here
E5 does stop 96 but I don't think that's
really helped as much
I'm gonna catch up on the chat reading
oh I got someone watching from
Philippines nice
I see a lot of D5 scares me I agree
oh D5 or white well that you know what
that actually does kind of scare me
I think D5 is definitely worth
consideration even if you're not going
to do it immediately definitely you
definitely need to think about it
all right
let's see
um I think I'm gonna give it another
couple of seconds just to kind of make
sure everybody is on the right on the
same page
sorry
anybody feels like they need more time
I really can't see faces that this is
too bright
okay I saw the thumbs up that's that's
good I see another thumbs up
I think D5 is pretty good actually
because D5 is very forceful
um the thing with D5 is I don't
necessarily have to take and I will most
likely just go Knight to five
and start attacking and even if you go
Queen A4 I may just I may just go up
here so what I was considering
potentially was maybe take take Queen A4
to kind of stop you know Knight A5 ideas
thank you so I think that would have
been a very interesting way to try and
play it so I like this queen A4 idea
just just because it messes up with my
plans
um
so yeah that was probably something I
would consider and after take now maybe
E5 or like Queen A4 or you know what
um I would most likely consider this
more seriously but let me see what big
brother says yeah take Queen A4 yeah
these ideas because I definitely want to
go Knight A5 actually maybe Point A4
first I agree I remember this was
something I thought about during the
game because I don't have this anymore
you'll just take it and I don't really
have this because you'll take that
so I take 24 or take those two would be
my
unhappy stuff
so my opponent was relatively generous
and he just played E5 now this doesn't
mean he's not going to take it so I was
like you know what let me just do this
Knight A5 before he starts taking and go
Knight Queen a force
um and he plays Queen E2 Queen A4 was
probably still possible but now I may
try to get a little bit more comfortable
with this take
and then like c8s
especially since this Pawn is now pinned
you can definitely try to stop the um
the attack but I I would still want to
consider this more seriously especially
since there may be some D5 ideas
you can't really take you may have to
take here which means my knight also
joins the party having said that I may
also consider D5 right now because you
can't take right and if you take then I
take with the Knights I still have to
deal with this though so I think there's
some calculation to be done here but
um this definitely makes me happy
okay
okay yeah I mean Patrick does fair
understand the names of positions is
really tricky so it's really important
to try to go back to Classics find a
good video that works for you try
because it's not all engine based some
of these like moves with 98 for example
delaying your D6 these are not
necessarily something that engine could
tell you a video or a book could do that
a whole lot more that's kind of why when
I'm teaching my students I'm usually
like okay so when you're trying to learn
the openings don't start with engines
start with a mixture of like videos just
like half hour video then try to go
through and input those video moves into
like literature study that's usually the
most convenient way and then do like a
mix of Master games and then start to
include like engine as like a last line
of thing just to make sure everything is
nice and good but you never want to
start with engine
unless you're playing like a super cool
weird line that is only engine
can help you and there's not like a lot
of videos or Master games that can help
you so that you kind of have to know
everything your engine says anyways
um Queen E2 so
question for audience what do you think
we should do probably no more d5s
immediately so what else
ah
what could we do now
yeah that's actually what I played too
it makes a lot of sense if you remember
the little like foreshadow that I did
um early on in our lecture I did mention
the idea with drug C8 and it would kind
of give you the possibilities to start
attacking on C4 so that is doing that
right now you may very well try to I
want to start eating on C4 so I'm
forcing my opponent's hands to either
try to play this Rook C1 which is
uncomfortable because District C1 also
leaves this Pawn hanging so yeah I may
take take you don't really have this
Roxy one because I have Knight B3 so
even just psychologically I am giving my
opponents a really really hard time
because opponents now has to actually
deal with a lot of like potential
threats that I have and opponent doesn't
have a whole lot of potential threats
opponent doesn't even have attacks on
the king side anymore since they closed
up they can't do a chore Kaboom they
can't really this Knight here is also
looking a little silly even if they like
relocate it which is a good idea for
them to do at some point the G4 won't
necessarily work either because I I
won't I won't take I'll just stay here
that's another reason why E5 is not
necessarily the best choice in this game
and generally when you are trying to
resolve the tension in the center you
need to be very very careful because
with the tension Center you may very
well
um
lock it up for worse or take something
when it's when it would only hurt you in
long term so tension in the center is a
beautiful gift for you so just learn how
to use it so
it's not always easy
but tension Center is a very big topic
and that is something that I actually
see a lot of my students have problems
with too so
uh yes so uh Rook theater is cool and my
opponent kind of felt like all right
well I gotta just take it because if I
don't this Pawn will be if they didn't
take it I would take in C4 Must Fall so
he took I took and now I'm like well I
can't really get my knight to D6 and my
Rook on C8 is feeling a little silly but
I do have a potential new cool spot for
my nights boom boom boom
so I started to calculate pretty much
immediately as I took I was like whoa
that pawn on V6 is gone now so I have
that square for my Knights so I already
talked about how much I don't
calculate when I play chess
um oh my God people shouldn't hold me
accountable for this video but I don't
do as much calculation because
I like to try to play more comfortably
and if I'm like if I'm sitting here and
calculating maybe I can do G5 you take
maybe I can do like this crazy line here
I would most likely not play the crazy
line and I would much rather play a more
strategic approach that I would have a
little but sure Advantage rather than a
super crazy line that's I make it's like
a cool tactic out of it but maybe not
so this doesn't mean I don't calculate
of course I calculate this whole line
and I also see that I may have
potentials for there I see potentials
there but it's more about noticing those
potentials and having better observation
skills rather than sitting here and
squeezing my head and calculating for 40
minutes although having said that I did
run into time travel in this game so
we'll get there too
so
um I did give you that little insight
into my brain to kind of wrap it up with
um the way I approach chess in the last
couple of years is more related to how
the position changed rather than
um just kind of staying hyper focused on
making super cool plans so I became way
more flexible with my planning so just
because I wanted to go up here and I
can't do it anymore I'm not gonna get
like upset I'm not gonna get hyper
focused on maybe I can go D6 maybe I can
go D5 I do still keep those ideas in
mind but I won't get obsessed over them
if that makes sense to you guys
um so for me noticing that this Pawn
structure changed I immediately go for
oh open file oh B6 Square so those are
the things that I noticed immediately
rather than
starting to calculate maybe I can take
maybe there's a cool tactic stuff like
that
okay
so it's a good idea to try to understand
how to develop those techniques about
how the position Changed For Better or
For Worse what changed for your
opponents what new weaknesses this is a
new weakness because they're double
isolated pawns what new strengths for
them this is technically an open file
and semi-open file so this may be
something they can work on the specific
Pawn
so yeah
so opponents try to grab this open file
good for them I was staying with my plan
I was staying with my plan I was staying
with my plan and opponent got there in
time to protect their Pawn but I got the
chance to kick that Brook away and now
I'm attacking this guy
and now I got Rook p8s D5 would also
been a really cool choice because of
take I would have C4 options
um so they could probably take over here
I could take with queen and it would
resolve my d-pawn issue and it would
give me more opportunities so I think
this would if I was playing this game
again I would consider D5 more seriously
but Rook B8 made a lot of sense for me
even when I played Rook B8 I didn't
think I'm winning I knew that I have a
lot of pressure and I knew that my
opponent is probably extremely
uncomfortable because I have like rugby
two night B2 potential Knight B3 I could
just wait and double up the Rooks and
this is not comfortable
just to show you I'm going to flip the
board
would you rather be white
or black
any white takers anybody want to be
white I see some head shakes
I see a very funny frown I think
yeah so
yeah thank you Brian Clark hey Brian
Clark it's been so long
I am sister of quarter direction there's
very few of us with the same last name
actually that's not true very few of us
in chess and the same last name
yeah
okay so
um having talked about all of those
my opponent was probably feeling
extremely under pressure too so he just
was like you know what buddy I'm just
gonna pull back uh I don't know if he
was worried about my knight B2 or my
Rook B2 or my Pawn D5 I don't know what
he was worried about uh you know
specifically but they he just went
backwards C1
which gave me rupee two options Knight
B2 options potential Knight P3 options
so I'm gonna take a second and ask you
to kind of calculate what would you want
to play here as black
I know I just gave you a whole spiel
about how much I don't calculate a whole
lot but this is one of those moments
that you do need to find some time and
energy to calculate so
the best way to try to calculate though
is to
figure out
um like candidate moves so Knight B2
definitely candidate move Rook B2 is a
candidate move Knight b3ism maybe for me
because my knight on A5 feels better
than their Knight on D2 and I to be also
completely transparent I don't think
engine is going to give me a whole lot
of Advantage
um probably very little maybe 0.05 I
don't think it's going to be anything
more than that but I was banking a whole
lot on my opponents making funny
mistakes because the amount of pressure
that I was putting them under it's I
mean he should have broke and he did so
try to also to give your opponents the
benefits of they will crack on their
pressure
so
keep that in mind as well
trading night for Bishops so I'm
assuming you're considering I'd be two
probably
sorry
yep I don't speak Spanish but I can see
D6 something Central
yes
so you don't like graffitially
I think so actually tell me what do you
think is White's best move after Rook B2
oops that will be my hair too thank you
and then you get 93 which is just
probably money
true so probably they have to move the
queen somewhere or play Rook B1
sorry
possibly
this is a very strategic position so if
you need an extra minute that's totally
cool
I actually think I spent about 15
minutes here so
this was a classical game 100
um
an hour 30.
oh
scary thoughts Knight takes C3
no no not yet
I'm getting a lot of night b2s and Rook
beaches in the chat
okay
actually I don't think that doing stuff
with the D7 Pawn is a bad idea I don't
think it's the right time just yet
so
um I'm gonna go ahead and say I played
Knight BL ah I played Knight B2 and I
was very pleased
um engine as I said like this is not the
best engine ever but it's still I mean
it's giving black
um Comforts level
but it's not really giving Advantage
like it's saying maybe Rook C8 maybe
Knight B2 I'm assuming is probably also
going to give me some like B2 at some
point I guess or not
um but I like Knight V2 Rook B2 I
thought that Queen F1
uh or like Queen E1 or even Queen D1
would be ideas that would be a little
annoying
so I didn't really go for that
um I however did go for Knight B2
now my idea with 9 Speed 2 is to be
honest very uncertain I'm attacking but
I have no intentions of taking it just
yet
um if you allow me I may try to eat this
Pawn but if it's my move again right now
like if you just play like a waiting
move I'm not going to take this I may
choose for D5
um let me actually close this up
but if you play Queen F5 which is
something I saw over the game I was like
oh man if you play this queen F1 in
between to go like this should be two I
don't really have a good follow-up move
it now it this does not mean that I'm
unhappy with my position but I was just
not sure what to do so I was kind of
banking and my opponents playing it's a
little weird and no good luck good for
me they did they did make a mistake
my opponent just kind of gave up on this
Pawn
I assuming I'm assuming because they
missed out on Queen F1 or they didn't
realize that they were not like losing
losing they were a little bit more
comfortable but because of the amount of
pressure that I have over them and
because of how uncomfortable this is for
them and they don't actually have pretty
much any threats against me I'm assuming
that's why they kind of broke under the
pressure so having said that I'm kind of
circling back to chess on psychology I
know Dennis is doing it now and I'm sure
she's a super teacher but just a
psychologist my baby so I always thought
that that's a good way to try to think
about Chess that is not your I mean
you're not playing a game you're playing
the person so try to make sure that you
give the person enough opportunity to
mess up and I did I thought Knight P2
would give my opponents the most
opportunity to mess things up
so Knight B2 uh he played Bishop C2 I8 I
think engine wanted me to wait with this
but I just took it to that
and I just pulled back I'm attacking and
I realized that I may try to trade
things off a little bit
um I momentarily considered like this
take and I was like well I don't really
know how to continue I may have like
some specific threats maybe this maybe
that and then I was like you know what I
have an extra Pawn I did what I wanted I
managed to get that fun it's okay to
kind of regroup
and my appointment C4 so
here I actually have a choice to make I
can try to go on C3 square or I could
choose this to eat this Pond which one
do you think would be more comfortable
that's what I did too
if you go see through you can redirect
to E4 that is also possible
so there's a lot of good choices to make
I think my issue with Knight C3 was
potentially if Queen C2 this might be a
little bit of an issue for me
potentially long term
and I thought if I like try to regroup
maybe like Bishop B5 I thought this
might become a little uncomfortable
again let me call on the big brother no
they like my C3 never mind ignore what I
said Knight C3 was totally fine actually
the engine likes it more I wanted to eat
the pawn because I thought long term
this would give me more comfort
and my opponent played Queen E3 and I
just went for simple tactics that I saw
at the point at this moment I just took
because my point is you take if they
take ah if they take I'm gonna give
check I'm gonna eat that and whoops and
I am very happy with this trait
so I went for it and I was happy and of
course I have two extra pawns so my
opponent didn't take it he took on F4
and I started to kind of push over here
I think this was a little over ambitious
I should have just went through T3 to
try to maybe go Rook D4 or try to like
get her to this Pawn because this Pawn
will be a big problem
I went to G5 and then I just kind of
tried to regroup this Knight which
they're all like healthy moves but they
give my opponent like opportunity and
opportunity I should have just played
Rook V2 here and if we trade off the
Rooks that's totally fine if we don't
trade off the Rooks where are you gonna
go with your queen you go the other way
cool I may even try to attack you
because this would be a pretty cool
attack or I may just pull it back
I think Knight B6 was a little extra
prophylactic so it wasn't really cool so
um again like here something like Pawn
A6 may have been a little bit more
comfortable because if you take then
maybe I can try to eliminate this Pawn
because I might the majority of my pawns
are in this side so that's the site that
I will be playing in the long term but I
just played like F4 and it felt nice
because I was like this is a very
annoying Pawn if I can get rid of it
I'll be great
Queen G7 would have been a nice choice
too
so after I form my opponent Pedro key
one I went F3 and he played rookie three
so question what do you think we should
do here there are a couple of things
that are totally good to do
um which one do you think would be the
best
foreign
I also agree Yasser does usually take
the poems
yeah to be fair or if face direct would
have been sweet simple I don't know why
I didn't do it
I tried to keep my trend of let's trade
off more and I took over here and I went
over here and I took over there and then
I was like why did I just do that
because now you have two pawns that may
cause me some harm why did I just give
my opponent that extra opportunity so it
would have been so much more comfortable
if I just take over here
and I just push over here or take over
here or whatever the bishop is not going
to be active pretty much ever my knight
is happy where it is the knights is
protecting over here attacking over here
protecting this so your Bishop can't go
this is a perfect night
I mean it's paralyzed but slows are
efficient so I'm happy with that I
should have played that but I was in
time trouble so I just kind of rushed
into trading stuff off more and more and
then I was like oh this is so bad
um again engine is still giving it a
good chunk of Advantage just giving it
minus three pretty much because I have
like two extra pawns and I should have
taken but I didn't and I just pushed and
then I was again like oh my God why am I
doing this I had some ideas here I was
like look if I can get my coin to this
diagonal or if I can get my queen
somehow to eat this guy and go back here
I'm gold
and then I was like well how's that ever
going to happen my queen is stuck to
these
this one is definitely gonna fall sooner
or later so how am I planning on
activating this so I was like okay let's
go protect this guy attack this guy step
by step we'll come up with the next plan
opponent played Rook D1 and then I was
like okay let's go over here and as soon
as I played it I was like whoa whoa whoa
this was not a good choice I should have
simply tried to stay with my plan to go
attack this Pawn I went to Queen F Queen
G7 to attack E7 E5 and opponent took and
I took and
for again we were both playing on
seconds here so it was really hard to
actually find the time to calculate but
question
if opponent trades off the queen is that
good or bad for them
they do have like two less pawns at the
moment
why
uh
D7 and they're attacking they're on the
seventh grade
they would lose B5 and most likely A3
but yes
it would be
terrible for me
yes as soon as I took that I was like
wait a second I didn't calculate the
Rook end game because if they take take
Rook takes D7 Rook takes B5 Rook takes
A7 what am I gonna do like Rook B2 and
then I'm my king is stuck their King is
stuck that would be a draw
but my opponent also didn't figure it
out on time and he just he just kind of
went ahead and gave this check yeah
sorry
hold on my opponent just went ahead and
gave this check and I think they missed
this true Cafe idea uh they thought
maybe I move up and they take and no no
not today and my opponent took over here
defending this but if I finally got my
queen ledge too and now I knew I'm good
now I know I'm winning
but this was a good kind of wrap-up of
the game but it got really scary for a
minute there because I simply
miscalculated
um actually not miscalculated but I kind
of like gave my opponent too many
opportunities he resigned here if I'm
not mistaken I give too many
opportunities around
like this trade like this was like they
should have taken it I should have taken
this a little back here like this bishop
is not a good Bishop why would I relieve
this bishop of the of you know why would
I just kick it off I should have just
taken over here and kept these guys here
and just take over here that would have
been so much more comfortable because my
D7 Pawn would be very well protected
with a knight
another thing that I started to kind of
mess up a little by little nobody's
attacking any of these guys I don't I do
not need Knight B6 I don't know why I
played it I could have simply just
played Rook B2 put the Rook on the
second rank see how things go
um G5 was fine but like there were a lot
of like little moves like that or like
actually here I think Knight takes G2
would also be interesting because if
take then I could take over here and I
mean this is fine too but I thought
tonight the F4 Pawn would be more worth
it
but you see like little by little I
started to give my opponent advantages
so I didn't really like that I didn't
like how I gave my opponents
opportunities to make me regret my life
choices
um yeah so this take would have been
devastating
I think that would have made my
scholarship be questioned but anyways
um so I managed to kind of get a hang of
it and use this specific Pawn a whole
lot but yeah
just because you don't necessarily need
to calculate as much doesn't mean you
shouldn't there are points that you do
need to still calculate but I think the
main thing that I played in this game
was
I mainly played my opponents and I
really put him under a lot of pressure
so that's definitely gave me a lot of
the points and
um
I really like that I handled the opening
very well and the middle game so as soon
as I got the pawn though I started to
kind of
get a little bit more
um I don't want to say careless but I
think I got I got two like in my head
and I was like I want to make sure that
I keep those pawns and I want to play
more careful so that's probably
um something that I would try to do
differently and yeah but overall it was
it was a cool game I like this game so a
big recommendation make sure to
definitely well follow subscribe all
those but after you do that I have a
playlist of like 100 plus videos that
I've done previously for the chess club
so go start washing those and
um I think the first one is the other
one that I've done at Giants nimzoo or
opening slash game so if you liked this
video with the specific Pawn structure
make sure to watch the other one too and
I will be back on YouTube for a big
chunk of time and like second half of
May and early June so watch out for that
but yeah besides that it was a pleasure
being here today everybody and I hope to
see everybody soon again
[Music]
foreign